un derby blinois sulfureux au 8e tour de
la coupe de france versailles recevait
poissy ce dimanche 28 novembre au stade
mob auront après une entame de match
versailles est ponctuée par quelques
occasions voici se reprend les jours
pissia qui poussent pour marquer mais
n'arrive pas à concrétiser leur
offensive les équipes se séparent sur un
score nul et vierge à la pause 0 à 0
première mi temps
c'était plutôt le mutant à notre
avantage en début de match on a mis un
peu de temps à entrer dans le match et
ensuite plus tôt le plus tôt me donne un
autre avantage dans la conservation du
ballon dans l'utilisation on va dire que
sur les dix premières minutes on a été
très bien en place discipline et on a
récupéré des ballons hauts on a mal
exploité on n'a pas assez utilisé cette
profondeur
voici a repris un peu plus la maîtrise
du ballon notre gardien fait une parade
sur la première mi temps au retour des
vestiaires les deux équipes qui évoluent
dans la même poule en nationale 2
continue de se neutraliser le tournant
du match intervient la 75e minute
christopher iba y marque sur cette
action à 1 0 poissy poussé croire
revenir au score mais le but est refusé
pour hors jeu voici n'obtiendra pas de
penalty sur cette dernière action
versailles se qualifie pour les 32e de
finale de l'épreuve presse a juste fait
une grosse rencontre où on s'est tous
donné que ce soit les joueurs titulaires
et ceux qui sont rentrés on a tout donné
et on a le résultat final donc ça fait
plaisir frustrant parce que
versa une aucune situation
six semaines sur notre but qui on le
sait est une manière pour pouvoir passer
faut être efficace aujourd'hui on n'a
pas été comme bien souvent d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça qu'on ressent souvent des
matches comme ça frustre f le tirage au
sort aura lieu ce lundi 29 novembre avec
un objectif en tête pour les versaillais
aller le plus loin possible peu importe
l'adversaire et pourquoi pas une équipe
de ligue 1